alors on s'est connu au bain douche moi
ça va pas mal ouais c'est ça le truc
bonsoir Julien bonsoir merci d'être à la
première de bonne minuit est-ce que tu
sais sur quelle chaîne
et beaucoup de challenge
ma télé
maintenant vous êtes plus
alors on s'est connu au bain douche moi
ça va pas mal
[Rires]
alors on s'est connu au bain douche
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu que tu
fasses la première émission est-ce que
tu sais que le 14 septembre c'est
l'enregistrement de la première de Bad
minuit mais c'est aussi une date
extrêmement importante est-ce que tu
t'en souviens un petit village encore
une certaine Virginie coupée
bonsoir on est là sur la peau noire
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3
qu'est-ce qui t'a fait comme cadeau pour
ton mariage pour les deux ans
[Rires]
je pense qu'il faudrait quelque chose de
plus conséquent
est-ce qu'il est toujours aussi gentil
qu'il y a 2 ans
avec toi le plus souvent tout seul avec
moi
alors Julien tu donnes ton avis sur
beaucoup de choses là on t'a vu à 7 sur
7 a fait une chanson sur la peine de
mort et puis beaucoup de beaucoup de
chanteurs s'expriment sur les tas de
sujets et notre ami film kelkrotte et
notre ami Bernard il est vie on fait
tout un débat pour dire que maintenant
c'est un peu dommage quand même ce soit
les chanteurs qui parlent et puis les
philosophes alors qu'est-ce que tu en
penses toi ouais je suis un peu de leur
avis
quand même
alors je te demande ton avis sur ce qui
se passe en Nouvelle-Calédonie par
exemple
je n'ai pas la solution des problèmes
là-bas en Nouvelle-Calédonie
tu penses pas que le sens de l'histoire
c'est quand même que la
Nouvelle-Calédonie soit indépendante un
jour ou l'autre tu penses que
il y a eu des écrits là-dessus quand on
dit des choses beaucoup mieux que moi et
Le Pen qui dit que les chambres m'agaces
c'est pas important tu en penses quoi ça
voudriez poser la question tout à
l'heure à notre prochaine invité qui a
une excellente réponse je veux pas la
lui prendre parce que si jamais vous
l'avez posez
encore qu'il sera sûrement assez vite
vous en trouvez une autre mais enfin
c'était un dessin que j'ai pas d'avis à
vous donner là-dessus c'est indécent tu
donnes plus ton avis sur les sur l'effet
de société cette année c'est pas ça mais
enfin je veux dire après après un
jugement pareil j'ai dit c'est trop
indécent j'ai pas d'avis à donner c'est
la révolte j'ai pas mettre à me révolter
devant vous tu veux qu'on parle du Rex
alors
en passant en passant c'est quand on
fait comme chez Drucker alors c'est
quand le Rex
en janvier
pour combien de temps
pour un mois et demi un mois et demi et
pourquoi tu as choisi le Rex
ça change de verser alors tu sais que la
nuit il y a des gens formidables tu le
sais parce que tu sors pas mal la nuit
et qu'il y a des photographes qui font
des photos alors nous à bain de minuit
on en a un qui s'appelle Sylvain bergère
qui a fait des reportages pour nous
toutes les semaines et on va voir le
premier reportage sur notre machine elle
te plaît notre machine tu la mettrais
dans ta salle de bain en machine non tu
la mettrais pas dans la salle de bain
ça a été fait par un artiste qui
s'appelle Puccino
mais j'en mettrai pas ma salle de bain
malheur c'est que ma femme risque de le
faire et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu